all right guys
bang bang he's back zooby what's up man
how's it going bro i'm good man all
right uh the first time that we did this
we did it in new york on your epic
trip around america we were just joking
that uh zubi had
you'd never been to the us came for a
number of weeks and literally went to
every single american city i think met
all 330 million americans while you're
here
yeah so i i had been to the u.s before
but it was my first time going for
career reasons
and it was my first time going for such
a long period of time so i was out there
for
nine weeks in total and um yeah i went
to
i went to how many different cities did
i go to wait did i say i was there for
nine weeks i think it was longer than
that wasn't it
i think it was twelve about yeah maybe i
think
like i was watching it so you went you
did the joe rogan podcast
you did one of these podcasts kind of
city by city and then all of a sudden on
instagram you were in the white house
i was like yeah yeah yeah i was like
wait what is going on right now
yeah man that's the that's the power of
twitter right there people tell me that
twitter is useless and i'm like man you
just
you just don't know how to use it um
tell us the story how did you get into
the white house
um i tweeted on a couple days before
saying
can anyone get me into the white house
and then i got two invitations
there's people who work there who follow
me on twitter i didn't even know that
yeah
i've i've got fans in the white house
when i was in the white house i got
recognized in there like people were
like oh you're zooby yeah
i was like wait what
the next question then is like yeah
where's the oval office right
dude is crazy man um i mean i got i i
went to the pentagon a couple days
before that
because um yeah one of my one of my fans
works in the pentagon and he just dm me
and was like hey man i can give you a
tour of the pentagon if you're
if you're around and i was like you know
i'm i i'm like man if you get invited to
the pentagon if you get invited to the
white house go
so um what was that so i did you did
while you were in the us
oh wow so many things man so many things
um
so yeah i went to like 10 different
cities in total so i started out in
california
went to la and san francisco and la
obviously got on some of the some of the
biggest podcasts in the country and in
the world i did um the joe rogan
experience
the reuben report uh the ben shapiro
show did a whole bunch of podcasts over
there
and then um you know i went to san
francisco after that i was in texas for
a couple weeks
and the coolest thing was just um being
able to connect with so many people man
um you know of course i met yourself in
new york i did uh
michael malice's podcast when i was in
new york and i did meetups in different
cities as well
so i i first experimented it with it
when i was in san francisco
so it was like 6 p.m and i was just
hungry and i just put out a tweet saying
hey i'm in san francisco
if anyone's around and wants to go get
some food let me know and i got like a
whole bunch of people dm'd me and were
like yeah yeah like
let's meet up and stuff so that i did it
sort of as an experiment
and that was really cool so i think i
had like you know like ended up going
out for dinner with seven or eight
people
which was cool and then i was like okay
okay this is something i can do so i did
the same thing in nashville i did it in
atlanta
in new york in dc i mean new york and dc
had a lot of people came like a lot of
people came and i didn't even sort of
publicize it i
just told people like dm me and i'll
work something out and
find the details but it was amazing just
um
seeing you know being the online world
is cool
but as we all know like connecting with
people in the real world
and just seeing the the fact that that
was even possible the fact that i can
just drop into a city i've never been in
my life and just post up and say hey
who wants to meet up and then i'm next
thing i know i'm out for dinner with 30
people
um that's just awesome and the amount of
love i received the amount of support
everything like that was just um was
just fantastic so i'd say
you know i wouldn't be able to sort of
just say one experience but
sort of the general level of love and
support i received out there was just
awesome
and it feels like all of this is made
possible by this idea of like an
individual creator right so
you recently had this tweet that said
i've never signed with
a record label uh never had a manager
nor agent but i've gained 450 plus
thousand followers
uh 10 million plus video views sold 25
000 plus albums
2500 plus books six figures in
merchandise and performed in eight
countries
screwed the gatekeepers do it yourself
which like
of course everyone on the internet loves
right it's just like the ultimate like
middle finger to the man
but just talk a little bit about kind of
like what has this been like in terms of
really being one of the quintessential
examples of like
what is possible as an individual
creator today yeah man it's been hard
and you know
like a lot of people don't realize how
long i've been going for
so i released my first album in 2006 so
14 years ago which it doesn't feel like
that but i released my first album 14
years ago
so it's kind of weird how because so
many people who now know me just
discovered me in the past 18 months
so a lot of them sort of think my whole
career started with a viral tweet and
it's like no i mean even on twitter i've
been on twitter for it since 2009.
i've been on facebook since 2004. i've
been using these things for a long time
i've been going out there i've put out
eight albums and eps
i've been every city in the uk done
loads of tours and stuff
just been grinding and hustling and i
was doing it all before it was cool
in the music world now it's sort of cool
to be perceived as an independent artist
but when i started out it wasn't cool
everyone wanted to
people wanted to get signed everyone
wanted to be with a label
um you know it was then it was you know
unsigned or signed now people say
independent i was saying independent
from the beginning because i was like
i'm look i'm not even
unsigned suggests that i'm trying to get
signed and i'm not trying to get signed
i'm independent i want to own my own
stuff in terms of the business in terms
of creativity
in terms of the direction i want to go
in etc and
i think so many things are made possible
by that and you just
are able to to maintain the control
which
is ultimately important and the more
a lot of people ask me if i'd sign to a
label or why i didn't etc and
people who tend to ask me that tend to
be people who don't know that much about
the music industry and the ins and outs
like people
people who know about the music industry
tend to intuitively understand
why someone may not want to take that
route
um it's it's just a very shady industry
in a lot of ways and
in i don't know how many thousands of
artists have been screwed over by
signing bad deals and
just getting caught up in things that
they have no control over
and i never wanted that to be me and i
also realized with the tools available
with the internet with the ability to uh
you know have cds printed with the
ability to get your music
out now on uh when i first started it
was pretty much just
physical copies right cds and then you
had the
you know itunes became more popular and
then things shifted to streaming
and you don't need you don't need
anybody for
that right it's the same with um i wrote
and released my first book
last year strong advice which is now
sold a couple thousand copies and
i didn't i just wrote it and i just put
it out there it's not even on amazon
right i didn't go through any publisher
i just did it and that's what i do like
i don't ask for permission to do things
that i want to do
and a lot of people seem to be sitting
around waiting for some kind of
approval or
[Music]
permission or something recognition
something like that and i'm always
trying to tell people like you don't
you don't need that right you don't need
permission to start a podcast you don't
need permission to start a youtube
channel to release an album to
make a book whatever just just create it
and then
you can also find the audience and you
can reach them often for free
and you will if you can find your
audience then
you're kind of good to go you're just
beholden to them
so i think part of this is one you have
to have that mindset
right so you got to understand what the
advantages are two you've got to kind of
be a self-starter right in terms of
um it's really your effort your time
everything
but the other piece of this that i think
is interesting is
this is the ultimate kind of filter for
value
right because there's a whole bunch of
things that the the legacy system can do
in terms of marketing and
it may be a shitty book but it ends up
actually being successful
right because they just put a lot of
dollars behind it whatever when you're
doing stuff yourself
either the music good and people like it
or they don't the book's good or it's
not
right and so it really is kind of um it
lives on its own to some degree
and so does that apply more pressure do
you think or is it actually kind of
freeing
understanding that like the value you
create is ultimately going to be
determined by the audience
yeah it's a good question i mean i don't
think about pressure a lot i'm not
someone who really
deals with a lot of feelings of stress
or pressure or anything like that i ca
i kind of just do what i want and create
what i want and i believe that
hey you know everything i everything i
do i know it'll be successful to some
degree
i don't know how successful it's going
to be i don't know how many people
will like this song or want to buy this
book or
want to listen to whatever but i know
that you know hundreds will
thousands will and that's fine
right not everything needs to be a a
blockbuster it's not like um
you know in a lot of the mainstream
industries especially in entertainment
right they're they're reliant on block
but blockbusters
so i think that the majority of movies
that hollywood puts out lose money
but then they make it back up with
interest on the ones that are super
successful
same goes with a lot of um record labels
and things like that that's why they
care so much about first week sales and
second week sales like
to me that's yeah cool i want to get a
good launch but
i don't plan to sort of just push it
really hard for a couple weeks and then
stop it's like no
like i wrote my book i released my book
just over a year ago
and i'm still promoting my book it's
still selling at the same rate that it
was selling
when i first in fact it might be selling
faster now because more people
know me etc so and it's evergreen
content
so just keep going and um
yeah i think a lot of pressure is sort
of imagined i think a lot of people
psych themselves out you get this with
some people who want to start things but
they never do it because they're
worried that they don't have all the
information or it's not going to be
perfect or they're worried about people
judging them etc
and i'm always trying to just give
people that push of like look just just
do it put it out there
and at the worst no one's going to care
because no
one sees it but even if you get a little
bit of negative feedback or whatever
it's like cool just
keep it moving like you can keep
improving and you can
you will grow and develop over time
because you get better at things by by
doing them
right you're not going to step foot and
anything new
that you do you are going to suck at
right that's just the reality right you
to get to get good at something
you have to go through the stage of not
being good at it but staying at it
and then over time you develop your
confidence you develop your ability
and so on and there you go now you're
you know in in a long enough time scale
you actually become an expert
at the thing that you initially sucked
at you can take the best the best guitar
player in the world
the best anything in the world right the
first time they did it
they probably like there's no one who
just picks up a guitar
and intuitively knows how to play guitar
like if you see someone amazing at
guitar or drums or some instrument or
whatever
they also went through that stage of
being terrible
any person you see any youtube channel
you see man this guy's got 10 million
subscribers this podcast has millions of
downloads this
it all started from zero everyone starts
from zero so
yeah people sort of psych themselves up
too much by comparing where they are now
to where someone else is but not
considering how much experience and
effort and time etc
that person has put in um i can use a
gym analogy here like i get people who
see me lifting in the gym and
if it's someone who's like new to it
especially teenagers they'll come up to
me like man
i wish i had your genetics and i'm like
dude
you know if you saw me when i was like
15 or 16 you wouldn't have been you
wouldn't have been saying that right i
mean
i weighed more when i was 15 than i
weigh now like 18 years later
so i wasn't just sort of born jacked or
with a six-pack or anything it's like a
lot of work has gone into it but
once someone reaches that level it looks
it looks like
luck or just innate talent when
oftentimes there's
a crazy amount of hard work that's gone
into it yeah and one of the things that
uh if you take podcasts for example or
any sort of creative endeavor where
you're putting content out
uh a lot of people will are willing to
work hard for
a month or three months or six months
they don't really have kind of the the
dedication and persistence to go
years and years right so you're talking
about hey you started you know 2007 2008
and kind of been doing this for a very
very long time
if you go when you look at the top
podcast you know joe rogan started in
the late 2000s right you look at the tim
ferriss
like all of these folks have started
very early on and so kind of
2007 to 2013 time frame and they worked
hard
for a decade or more right and i think
that's part of it is like it's the hard
work but then it's also the persistence
to stay with something for a long period
of time
and you've done that over and over and
over again so where do you think that
comes from
it's because i know why i do it and
beyond that i enjoy it it's those two
things so i've got a very clear vision i
mean
my goal in life is to have a positive
impact on over 10 million people
through my words and my actions and you
know 10 million people on an ongoing
basis i want to have like 10 million
people i can consider fans
and so that drives everything it drives
my music it drives my
my podcast you know doing interviews
like this or writing books
doing public speaking whatever it is
each time i'm reaching new people
and it's like okay cool i was impacting
a hundred people now it's 500 oh for now
it's 5 000. and now it's 50
000 and cool like now millions of people
have at least heard of me and
you know hundreds of thousands are
following and getting the message
hey they're tuning in to see what is
going on even if that's just on social
media that's a sign they're interested
to some degree
so that's what drives me it's um
i don't know exactly where that sort of
innately comes from wanting to have such
a
such an impact on the world but i know
that that's what motivates and drives me
so it's very easy
well relatively easy for me to get over
any
obstacles or difficulties and i look
i've had um
i mean i i left i left my full-time job
in november 2011. so i've been full-time
self-employed since
almost nine years now and i used to be a
management consultant and i literally
quit being a management consultant
to go and become an independent
full-time rapper
which is like you know
by a lot of people's ideas probably be a
terrible idea right because
you're taking something that's very
stable and has a clear career
progression
to go and pursue something that's so out
there and keep in mind like i'm an
oxford university graduate so people are
like well
wait you you could have gone to like
silicon valley and you know
joined the sort of you know the startup
world or you could have done this or you
could have done that or whatever i've
got
friends and family you know investment
banking or you know you could do this
there's all these options and it was
like you know i want to be a rapper
like this is this is what i want to do
and i know i can't reach this goal of
impacting millions of people
doing what i was doing before right if
i'd stayed in that career line you
wouldn't know who i
am that white house trip wouldn't have
happened i would have never been on joe
rogan
i would have never had all these cool
opportunities to do what i'm doing now
and impact all these people i'm
impacting now
so for me personally that's what drives
me and also the things i do i genuinely
love like i genuinely enjoy making music
i enjoy having conversations with people
i enjoy
fitness i enjoy putting out content etc
so
that also helps because if you enjoy it
then it doesn't really feel so much like
work
and i think the secret to your success
we talk about hard work and kind of the
the longevity of it but also you tell
the truth
right you're super authentic and you're
willing to say things that you
you believe it's very obvious you
believe them uh sometimes those are
things that are kind of consensus in
society and sometimes those are things
that go against the consensus
and so how do you kind of get
comfortable doing that and kind of
what was the impetus for you to say look
i'm just going to be super transparent
and
kind of honest with people uh regardless
of how the audience feels
yeah sure so you get used to doing it by
practice
just like everything again another gym
analogy right you put in
you put in the reps you put in the sets
you you keep doing sessions and
you know first time you walk in the gym
you probably can't you know deadlift 500
pounds or
bench press i don't know 250 pounds or
whatever unless you're a freak
but you put in the time you keep doing
the reps and over
time you get stronger and you get
stronger and you get stronger and you
you become resilient
and you get to a point where it's like
okay i've actually you know i've met
if i were to estimate how many people
i've met in real life this is not online
i've probably met in real life and had
conversations with
400 500 000 people all right
so i've sold 25 000 albums hand to hand
that's how i used to sell my cds so you
can imagine
to sell that many albums how many people
you need to actually speak to and engage
with so
i developed a really really really thick
skin over those years right
and anyone who's ever done direct sales
or direct promotions you you develop a
thick skin because you know you deal
with constant rejection
you deal with people being rude people
not understanding what you're doing
people not caring about what you're
doing
so when it comes to online stuff i'm
like man whatever you know people are
like oh how do you
what if you tweet something and someone
gets angry i'm like do you think i care
like i don't
you know and and i don't go out of my
way to raw people up
i don't consider myself a provocateur
sometimes i know some things i say like
it's going to get a reaction
but it is rooted in authenticity it's
rooted in
it's rooted in kindness and compassion
it's rooted in wanting people to know
the truth and to tell the truth and not
be deceived etc
and also just wanting to put my own
opinion out there and if
if people disagree that's totally fine
if people agree that's totally fine
we can have conversations i enjoy
sparking conversations
so um and and this is interesting as
well because i didn't used to do that i
used to keep my
views and opinions especially on
anything contentious i used to keep it
very very private
um and i just have these conversations
with friends and family in private
and the reason i actually stepped out of
there
which is not something a lot of people
know it's because in 2018 i there was
actually a situation
that sort of happened which just made me
realize
how far things were going in a certain
direction
and i just thought okay i need to i need
to speak up
because stuff is getting it's getting
it's getting gnarly out there and
the world needs more sane voices another
reason why i didn't used to do that is
because i thought that
i never used to think that my views and
opinions or my thoughts were
particularly interesting
right even now like a lot of the stuff i
say i think it's relatively
common sensical and somewhat mundane and
i feel like i shouldn't really have to
say it
but the weirder the world goes and the
more that other people are lying and
deceiving people and stuff
the more refreshing people find it to
just have you know individuals out there
who are just willing to
have conversations and share their
honest thoughts and
not be wanting to i don't know silence
people or
uh you know just sort of fit in these
weird boxes
that people think they're going to be in
or whatever and again you you get this a
lot in music and entertainment i mean
it seems like every single person in
music has the exact same views on
everything which
is quite a clear sign that somebody
somebody's lying you know
somebody's lying how does every
celebrity have the same view on
everything like that doesn't
that i don't really buy that um
and yeah people get locked into these
positions and
as you're saying you know a lot of these
people are beholden to others so
with me being independent uh right you
know if someone has a problem sometimes
i'll jokingly say that they should speak
to my manager if they have a problem
talk to my boss and it's like you know
and that's that's a
that's a great feeling um and it's cool
to just not ha
not to be beholden to you know
i mean i don't know imagine if i was
signed to a label or if i had a manager
or something they'd probably be
calling me three times a day asking me
to like delete tweets and social media
posts and
just delete that one delete that one i'm
like no
like that's that's what i think that's
what i feel um
but i feel like that that's the power of
what you've built
right it is um i joke all the time and i
say that like uh
these we'll call them personal media
companies you call it independent
artists you call it whatever it is
like you essentially build this uh fan
base of people
who subscribe to you right and so you
create a book they want it you create
music they want it you say something on
twitter they want to hear about it right
like
they are all in and they align with you
whether it is on your perspective
on uh your you know creative tastes
whatever but it also adds this element
of
uh making it much harder for somebody to
kind of
cancel an individual right because you
basically have this
um army of people who now you've almost
set your own consensus
right hey us you know for you 450 000
followers on twitter like
these half a million people are ride or
die
like like we're in this and what do you
do cancel all of us
right like that's not gonna be possible
and so it feels like that is something
that
more and more people are figuring out
you figured it out a decade ago and
have kind of spent time building it but
maybe talk a little bit about how you've
seen those times where you have tweeted
something that you know some people take
as controversial or they disagree with
and
kind of how they interact with you that
might be different than let's say
somebody who's just got you know 100
followers on twitter
oh wow i mean my twitter i mean
this in the past 30 days past 28 days i
checked my stats
my twitter's reached over 100 million
impressions
in the past 28 days which is absolutely
bonkers it's on track to hit over a
billion this year
um which is just absolutely nuts
um the engagement on there is just crazy
like three million plus every single day
so yeah man you know majority is
positive
of course but when you're reaching so
many people and so many of them
are outside of your sort of sphere of
your your fan base or your follower base
etc
of course you get the negativity you get
the misunderstanding you get insults etc
but like i said i mean you know i don't
really
i know why i do what i do and i know why
i say what i say
and so the thing i can't deal with is
being
is feeling like i'm being inauthentic or
feeling like i'm a hypocrite or feeling
like i'm saying something that i don't
truly believe
or i'm wearing a mask and i'm putting on
a facade etc
that's the stuff that would keep me up
at night that's the stuff that would
bother me
if it's like you know someone
with some random you know
cartoon avatar with eight followers and
you know wants to send me some message
telling me how awful i am it's like why
would i
care about that like i don't i
legitimately don't care
like the the opinions that i care about
are people who i care about the opinions
of people who know me
right like someone who knows me right if
my if one of my siblings or like my
parents or something was like oh you
know that's uh
you know checks me on something or it is
critical or something like i'm a lot
more i'm like okay i'm gonna listen
right i won't always agree but i'll
listen because it's like okay and this
is someone who actually knows me
and they're giving this perspective from
a place of love and i know that
or even if it's uh you know my fans and
my supporters if i put out a
i don't know if i put something out and
like my actual fans are actually my
supporters were like um like i don't you
know i don't like this or whatever then
like okay that's
you know and this doesn't happen often
but if it did then it's like okay well i
actually care about
these people's opinions but um you know
it's just like
you know if there's some i don't know
there are 300 million active users on
twitter and everyone's got an opinion
and everyone wants to throw their stuff
out there or whatever but
if you were walking down the street i
mean you don't care about the opinion of
like
a random stranger who has never has
never met you and doesn't know anything
about you or whatever like
you know you don't wish them any any
negative or any harm what if it's like
okay you don't you don't know me so
it doesn't really matter but then
someone close to you who you know it's
like okay well i care about your opinion
and i also don't want to hurt your
feelings etc so there's more of a
relationship there so that's kind of how
that's kind of how i view it so you are
one of uh
very few independent thinkers on the
internet at this point uh there's uh
kind of this
pursuit of consensus over truth which
yes you and i probably agree on is
is pretty stupid um help me understand
kind of
the view of the world from somebody
living outside the united states right
now
given the pandemic that's going on and
kind of the economic crisis
um what's generally the view of the
united states from overseas or kind of
other people that you talk to
over in europe i think the consensus is
i think i think the narrative i think
the narrative
is that um some countries including the
usa i think there's
the narrative is that they haven't
handled this
very well and you get that from
different angles right you have the
you have the people who are you know
think there should have been more
lockdowns and things should have been
you know people should have just grabbed
the reins of control and forced people
to wear masks and forced lockdowns and
instituted fines and stuff and then you
have the people who are you know
more libertarian-minded who are like the
lockdown was a disaster destroyed the
economy unnecessarily
for virus with a 99.9 survival rate
it didn't make sense to do this to make
all these people unemployed etc
and um you know there's i can understand
both of those perspectives
and but i think what we're witnessing
this year is just a lot of
i think we're seeing sort of every
every interesting phenomenon in human
psychology taking place
right cognitive dissonance mob mentality
confirmation bias like every you know
pop the politicization of things that
shouldn't be politicized
um people forming teams tribalism etc
we've seen all of this play out so much
over the past few months
and i think that
there are there are some things that are
really really obvious when it comes to
the whole pandemic situation and the
response to it that no one
wants to even be honest about and i can
understand why certain people don't want
to be honest about
i think one of those things is that
nobody
nobody had a freaking clue right no no
one wants to just admit that like okay
like
you know in just in january in january
they were saying there's no human human
transmission
right they said masks don't work don't
wear masks don't buy masks and then they
said
absolutely wear a mask if you don't wear
a mask you're going to kill my grandma
they said that you can't go out and
protest you remember they had the lock
down protests and people were clamping
down on them
a couple weeks later you've got
thousands out in the streets black lives
matters protests and you even have to
have health experts
saying that it's okay because racism is
a bigger virus
and the the goal post they said flat in
the curve
and then we flatten the curve right just
a couple weeks to slow the spread that's
how they
got everybody to comply that was months
ago now but the gyms are still closed
the churches are still closed etc
they just keep moving the goal posts and
no one wants to admit
okay we didn't know what was going on
and no one wants to admit
okay perhaps we overreacted and you know
this wasn't as bad as we thought it
would be at the beginning they were
saying the death rate could be three
percent to five percent
now it turns out that if you are
under the age of about 50 and you don't
have
big underlying conditions your chance of
survival is virtually 100
right you can look at the figures you
can see who this is impacting if you're
over the age of
you know 70 or so 65 70
yeah absolutely you want to be careful
you want to take more precautions
it would make sense to perhaps self
quarantine yourself you know take
additional measures
but no one wants to just admit any of
this stuff so people are still
pretending
that you know children are just as at
risk as
80 year olds which is not true they're
trying to pretend that people like
yourself and myself are just
as at risk and need to take the same
precautions as people in nursing homes
which we know is not true
we know so many things but no one
because so many mistakes have been made
and everyone's trying to
score political points and do this and
do that i mean even when it comes to the
medical advice even when it comes to the
so-called experts how many times have
the experts been wrong
right there are no experts because it
takes time to become an expert it takes
years there's no coronavirus experts
not for coven 19 because it's new and it
takes time to become an expert so
whatever is said needs to be taken with
a massive grain of salt and
there are just so many people just have
different dogs in the fights and no one
wants to be honest and everyone is lying
from the media to the politicians to
this to that there's too many
there's too many um conflicting
opinions and views and everyone wants to
win
and that's the that's kind of the
problem and so
like i don't talk about the pandemic a
lot because it just gets people people
just get so
freaked out and amped up and i mean you
were asking before
the call like what the situation is like
where i live and i was saying that the
you know the amount of cases and stuff
throughout this whole thing has been
um you know been very low and it's not
an i don't live in an area that's been
heavily impacted i live by myself i
don't
like ice i've been socially distancing
for a while regardless for the most part
and then like i had one day where i
tweeted something about the fact that i
don't wear a mask
and i got like people you would have
thought that i like admitted to like
being a serial killer or something the
way people responded
and it's crazy because people don't even
factor in the fact that like things are
different in different parts of the
world and in different places so
someone might be in a place that's
heavily affected and everyone's wearing
masks and what i'm like no one wears a
mask here like it's not
it's not i think like i can go outside i
can go to the party there's thousands of
people are out
people no people aren't even social
distancing those it's like well it's not
a heavily affected area
so the precautions here are not going to
be the same as in new york city
or even in london etc but the mask
itself has even become like a tribal
symbol it's become a political
to become politicized now it's you know
if you don't wear a mask you're a bad
person and you know we must force these
people
the whole thing's just it's just become
farcical at this point you know i think
it's
i've just kind of removed myself from
the conversation and it's just like
look i'm just gonna use common sense
like i've been doing the whole time i'm
gonna go about my business look after my
health
not try to put other people
unnecessarily at risk
um which i haven't been doing regardless
of what people want to say
and um yeah that's a a little bit of a
rant but that's
kind of no but but what it you're really
getting at here is uh
everyone wants to talk about the extreme
ends of this right so whether you see
mainstream media on both sides kind of
pulling and pulling and pulling to the
extremes
you get all the divisiveness all this
kind of stuff i do think that there's
this
group of people who are emerging right
and i put yourself myself in this
it's just like it's common sense right
and you keep you kept using that
terminology but like that's ultimately
what it ends up being
it's like look you know i joked i said
this tweet before and i was like you can
basically believe that like
police brutality exists racism exists uh
you know the virus is bad but doesn't
affect everyone equally and like
i went through like all the nuances
right and you can actually believe this
position
and this ties like everyone together in
a common sense perspective
and you get people who are literally you
know again they act like you're
murdering somebody in the street on
camera and like and they caught you
yeah like all right guys but i i wonder
how much of that is people trying to
appease
certain groups rather than have this
like independent thought
right so like when you think about it i
think one
it's obvious that like you're able to
critically think about some of these
issues
two you've got kind of the courage which
sounds ridiculous but you've got the
courage to say it out loud
but then three is you become a magnet
for other types of people who have this
independent thought right and so like
it kind of feels like the extremes of
the political spectrum or the way that
this information is talked about
they have a um a head start right
they've been doing this for years and
years and years
now all of a sudden there's this like
common sense group that they're saying
hey wait a second like i'm not
cool with either one of those extremes
like find me in the center find me with
common sense and like that group is
actually building in size now
yeah definitely i mean i think a lot of
people want look
it's it's natural and it's human to seek
approval of others
and it's also natural to
want to appear to be a good person and
so you see this with all these different
narratives
you know if you want to talk about
things that have happened with this year
why
why on one day were people posting black
squares on instagram right it's because
they think that that makes them a good
person
it's not because it doesn't do anything
right it's not gonna it doesn't stop
racism it doesn't
help police but it doesn't do anything
but people want to appear to be a good
person and it's very easy way to signal
that you are a good person and then you
can also admonish people
who and demonize people who didn't post
the black square right i had
white women unfollowing me on tw on
instagram
because i didn't post a black square so
like you know
despite me yeah you're a racist you're
so racist
yeah like it should be kind of obvious
that i agree with that you know my life
matters and
those of my family etc and i don't need
to post a black square on instagram
to sort of signal to the rest of the
world that i i believe that and i don't
like the sort of
performative virtue signaling um
or similar like i said you know with the
whole mask thing and the way people
responded right people
feel like good people you know they've
created this sort of narrative of like
good people want masks and not only do
they wear them but they want to force
everybody else to
and you know bad people don't right
there's been this whole kill kill your
grandma line which has sort of almost
become a meme at this point
no one has explained how someone who
doesn't even have the virus is going to
pass it on
but you know that seems to be details to
to people
um so i think yeah that's what's
happening it's
it's very performative it's people
wanting to fit in with their tribe and
signal to their tribe
it's people wanting to um you know show
that they are virtuous citizens and that
they're behaving well not only are they
behaving well but other people are
behaving poorly so
i'm gonna point out i'm gonna you know
you're getting a lot of seeing a lot of
these videos people running around with
their cameras and
you know shaming people for not wearing
masks or trying to shame people for this
or that and i'm just like
this is really this is really silly you
know it's really silly it's not
productive it doesn't unite people
either
and also it's just ineffective i mean if
you if you want to like look at the
facts and the data but
people are more emotionally this whole
year has been emotionally driven
it's it's very everything is very
emotionally driven
there aren't a lot of people who are
like okay let's just be
let's be reasonable let's be fair let's
not be like super partisan about this
let's just look at what works and what
doesn't work and
let's also just use common sense but
people don't want to do that and once
someone is dug into a position
then there's that sort of sunk cost
fallacy where they feel like they need
to just keep doubling down
and doubling down and doubling down no
one wants to just
admit and say okay you know like with
this whole virus thing right
you know it's been it's been bad and
it's been very bad in certain areas
but it's also true right that can be
true
and it can also be true that in many
ways and in many places
the reaction was very was there was a
huge overreaction
right was it necessary for 42 million
was it was 42 million americans lost
their jobs so far
uh the latest number as of today is 52
million americans in the last four and a
half months
52 million so what i mean what's that
that's like
maybe a quarter of the working
population i'd guess yep so
one in three basically okay one and
three so
that's with that number and then as we
know with the virus with the data come
out from the countries
strongly suggest overall it seems like
the
the chance of someone you know a random
person dying if they catch this virus
is less i believe it's under 99 point
it's it's their survival rate i think is
over 99.9 percent
right this doesn't mean that you want
those 0.01
to die but for 42
min for 52 million people in one country
to lose their jobs over
over the response to something with a
99.9
survival rate does that logically sound
does that sound reasonable and this is
not this is not considering
the long-term effect even in terms of
health even in terms of
people's livelihoods survival etc right
there's
people created this false binary which
which was like okay
completely kill the economy and save
lives
or save the economy and kill everybody
and it's like neither of those was those
weren't their true positions
it's like there you can you can have a
response
that is moderated and is not necessarily
one size fits all
and you can keep the economy going
because you have to remember
when i think when people think of
economy a lot of people think of like
the stock market or they think of some
trucks like no the economy is people
like i'm the economy you're the economy
if no one is working
then nothing like everything stops
working
um you'll notice that in the u.s
what do you think of the federal
government's budget every year so the
money they spend
what percentage goes to support people
over the age of 65.
oh boy what percentage i have
i have no idea um i'd guess it's pretty
s
insignificant though 40 percent oh 40.
oh
so 40 of the us government's budget
every year goes to support people over
the age of 65.
so wow here's why that number is
interesting to me
because it basically is showing that the
economy in terms of running
those are the people who are most kind
of susceptible to the virus
are also the people who get majority if
not you know almost 100 percent of their
livelihood coming from the government
right so whether the economy is open or
closed they're still getting
financial kind of benefit it's everyone
who's
basically on the lower end of the age
brackets
uh that are least susceptible to the
virus they're the ones who get hurt the
worst by the
uh shutting down of the economy right so
you have kind of this weird thing
where uh the people that you're trying
to protect could actually go into like
very hard
quarantine and you leave the rest of the
economy open you could save lives but
not
hurt you know the 20 30 40 50 year olds
right
yeah so when i saw that said i was like
i i i was with you i thought it was a
very small number when i saw it was
40 percent i guess i guess that makes
sense that's like is that like pensions
and
pensions all the social security i mean
just all kinds of different government
programs you know all that kind of stuff
and so again i think part of this is
like there
is not a black and white world right
there's this gray area where there's
probably a pretty intelligent solution
that can address both problems
um switching gears a little bit on the
economy itself
like how how do you view that right
in in the sense of every government in
the world seems to just be
printing a ton of money and basically
running crazy trying to deal with this
and
who knows if they know what they're
actually doing or not but but they sure
are trying a lot of different things
yeah i'm no i'm no economic expert but i
think um
again i think a lot of stuff is running
on emotion and short-term thinking
i don't think that a lot of people are
thinking clearly and
thinking of long-term consequences of
things so if you're talking about
governments printing money
we all know what that leads to right
that leads to inflation that leads to
debts and things that you know i'm
potentially my future children and your
future children our future grandchildren
are going to be
paying off um and no one wants to think
about that because
in the short term it's expedient even
politically right you guys are in
an election year and there's elections
coming up in november so
every single thing that has happened
happening and everything people are
saying it's also
being tainted by the idea of okay is
this going to help
or hurt us and our opposition
right so and that's a terrible situation
because
say for example if donald trump or the
republicans
have a a proposal or a bill
or something that's going to genuinely
help
americans there is
an incentive amongst people in the media
and the political opposition
to railroad it right and to block it
even if they knew
in fact because they know that it would
help
right they don't want that because they
know that's going to increase the
probability
of people voting for trump and him being
re-elected and everything and so
once people are thinking in these lines
it the what's best for people
is totally sidelined right they just
start thinking okay what's best for
our political strategy how can we
increase our chances of election etc
right there are people they probably
won't say it out loud
but there will be people who are really
really hoping that stuff does not
recover
because they don't want trump to be
re-elected right they they're so opposed
to him
that they would rather america suffers
and americans
suffer just so they can get this guy out
of the white house and as soon as you're
thinking that way
and and this could run in either
direction i'd say this the same if you
know if um
you know whoever was in power and the
opposition i just think that this is
very very clear
right now that people are just so
partisan and tribal that they just kind
of
they just want what is expedient in the
short term
and that's a shame um it's a shame and
it's actually it's actually a big
problem
and um yeah in terms of the economy i
don't
i don't know i don't know what the long
term repercussions are going to be i
think it's going to be
pretty bad i mean here in the uk they've
had this furlough scheme
so there hasn't been um
the unemployment numbers haven't sort of
hit as hard as they have in the us
what is the scheme so the government so
people are being furloughed so
essentially the government is paying
millions of people 80 of their salary
during this whole period right so the
government is
is paying people 80 so all the people
who are not working
the vast majority of them they've been
furloughed right
instead of just losing their jobs
outright but what this means is of
course
i don't know how much that's costing the
government but also
it means that a lot of the impacts are
delayed so in the us you you guys kind
of got hit like straight off the bat
boom 17 million this week
20 million this week etc but in the uk
we don't even know what those long-term
unemployment numbers
are going to look like because it's all
being sort of propped up
but it might come to sort of september
october etc
when the furlough scheme ends and then
you know some of these businesses have
shut down some of them are going to lay
off a bunch of people
some of them are going to convert more
to remote working etc so
we don't yet even know here in the uk
and perhaps in other european countries
what the sort of
impact is going to be even just later
this year it could happen that okay
millions of people
by december are now out of work even
though they sort of
feel like they're still being paid right
now but
they might go back and sort of get that
bad news etc and then of course the
long-term damage i don't
i don't know i don't know and taking
kids out of school for so long and
there are a lot of things that again i
just don't think people have really
really
people don't really sort of sit down and
consider and think about there was
the panic and you know the the panic and
the freak out was
it was initially justified right if the
thing if the virus really had a five
percent
kill rate then okay going on super
lockdown and
waiting until you've kind of got more
data and more information
and remember the thing was because they
didn't want the hospitals to be
overwhelmed et cetera but it's like okay
that happened
the curve got flattened hospitals were
not overwhelmed there was enough ppe
all these things that they were worried
about came to pass but then it was just
like
no more lockdowns more lockdowns more
lockdowns and it was like
even now people are literally calling
for the lockdowns to keep being extended
and when they get clothed and it's just
like there's got to be a
there has to be a transition plan here
right you can't this is not this is not
something you can just carry on
indefinitely without consequences what
it feels like almost is the government
saw this coming and they were like hey
you know what we're going to step in and
intervene and we're going to provide a
bunch of programs and ideas and
and even mandates in some cases to like
bridge the gap
right so if we're going to shut it down
there's a bunch of people who may lose
their jobs but
if we go on lockdown it'll be over in
four weeks and then we can kind of
bridge everybody
and then like the economy will reopen
and everything will be fine right
but i think to your point nobody thought
that this was going to still be going on
we're starting at the end of july now
right we're you know we're four and a
half five months into this thing nobody
thought it was going to go this long
and so you can see most of the programs
and you know in the u.s they have like
this beefed up on insur
unemployment insurance it ends at the
end of july right the
the uh ppp loans which basically they
gave to businesses to not fire employees
you can't fire anyone before the end of
september but on october 1st you can
start firing people okay so okay
so like kind of all these programs that
they had first put in place back in
march
actually end in july august or september
and so you know my thought was like
that's probably when they thought this
was going to be over by
but now like i don't think this is going
to be done
right and so in that case what do you do
and
you know look there's no right answer
but but it just feels like
you know in the uk in the us like
everyone everywhere is dealing with it
and your point earlier about just like
just say hey we don't know right we're
doing the best we can with the
information we have today
you almost set yourself up for better uh
response later on because people
don't say well you were acting like you
knew what was going on earlier
and you were wrong right when you kind
of approached it as
i don't know but here's the information
we have and we're going to make the best
decisions we can
i think people are less mad later on
because they understand
you know this is a human process that's
really built on just the information
you have yeah and the thing is and you
know telling the truth is not
incentivized
it's not incentivized i mean i remember
you know when boris johnson
fairly early in this situation he said
he said people are going to die
some of us are going to lose family
members and he was shellacked for saying
that even though it was the truth
it was the truth right some people will
die that is literally
the truth and you're not supposed to say
that as a politician you're not supposed
to say
some people are going to die but it's
the reality and it's also a reality that
we implicitly accept every single day
and when people you know don't
understand that i say okay why don't we
reduce the speed limit on highways
to 20 miles per hour why don't we do
that that would save more lives
that would save more lives than all of
the stuff we're doing right now
but we know that that is not
feasible right if you want to save lives
ban alcohol bend cigarettes
ban sugar right that'll save lives you
want to talk about saving american lives
saving british lives
i'll save way more than any coronavirus
but
people understand okay you have to
we all implicitly accept certain risks
in society and so every time you get in
a car and you drive on the highway every
time you do this
every time you do that we are taking
risks and not only is it for us right
because
we're we're also putting other people at
risk if i go and i drive my van on the
motorway i'm putting i'm putting other
people at risk right you know i'll drive
i'll drive my best but i could be a
hazard to somebody
right so we all do this all the time and
we've been doing this forever
but suddenly people are have like sort
of lost the plot and
aren't understanding that look we we all
take risks even when it comes to this
mask thing right 60 000 people a year
in america die of the flu 60 000 a year
that's half of the coronavirus and
their response is zero percent of what
their response has been
right and that also kills children by
the way right coronavirus doesn't really
affect kids flu does kill children
and no one like flu season you don't
even know it's flu season right no one's
wearing a mask no one's social
distancing
people are just getting on with things
and taking normal precautions
and nobody thinks about it because the
media doesn't spotlight it and highlight
the fact that 60 000 people
there's no running you know flu death
count on the news etc
so people respond in a very different
way and it's
if you have the power of the media and
you know how to sort of use data and
statistics to your advantage
it's very easy to make people freak out
over things right i mean and you you see
this with so many things i mean
right now you know you have people
running around talking about how there
is an
epidemic of police brutality
and police killings no there's not no
there isn't
right and a video online look what we
all agree
what happened to george floyd and what's
happened to some in similar cases
is absolutely terrible and should never
happen
but to say that it's an epidemic to say
that this is like every day
this is everyday life for black and
white i'm like no it's not right that's
hyperbole that's that's emotion
that's feelings that's taking an
anecdote and
extending it across millions of millions
of people where it doesn't make sense
and
again you're not supposed to say that
because it upsets people and it's not pc
and it hurts people's feelings and
you're supposed to say yes i agree
there's an epidemic and we must do this
and we must we must defund the police
and all cops are bad etc and it's like
no that's just not
it's just not it doesn't reflect reality
and
i don't know like uh it's easy to sort
of have this conversation on a
one-to-one basis or like with a small
group but
if you try to do that on any type of
public platform let alone if a
politician came out and said some of the
things i'm saying right they'll they'll
be
calling for their heads tomorrow just
because you're you're not supposed to
say the truth
yeah but it gets back to consensus over
truth right
everyone wants to pursue the consensus
via the truth and the part to me that
i think has just uh hitting me over the
head is
how much society lacks good
grounding in science and math right i
mean if you really think about this
by the way i'm not an epidemiologist
neither are you right i'm not a
mathematician neither are you
but there's some basic things that
everyone should be armed with
right and and being able to kind of see
a problem
and be inquisitive enough or kind of
intellectually curious to go get the
data
look at the data and be able to make
very very clear distinctions between is
this
statement or this consensus
directionally true or not
it feels like we just haven't armed
people with that science and math kind
of understanding to do it because you
literally see
you know my favorite is uh they keep
showing um
the aggregate amount of cases in uh
countries
so they'll compare you know a country
that has nine million people with a
country that has 330
oh yeah yeah and all they'll say is you
know well this country has a hundred
thousand cases this country has you know
only
a thousand it's like hold on a second
timeout like yeah
dude taking one step further we have no
flipping idea
how many cases there are we don't know
we have no idea like we literally have
no idea
how many cases there are like you're
you're in uh
you're in europe so you probably didn't
see this but uh in the united states
there was an article that went uh
viral across a lot of these kind of
non-mainstream media
but basically i think it was in florida
a guy died
in a motorcycle accident oh yeah like
literally motorcycle accident
coveted death and now look i understand
the financial incentives that the
hospital or whatever gets paid if it's a
covenant like it makes complete sense
when you understand what the incentives
are
but that's the type of stuff where that
one kind of anecdote
i come out and say we don't know i don't
know if it's over counting or under
accounting
because there's a whole bunch of data
you can look at that can tell you both
stories but what i do know is that guy
probably didn't die from cove and he
probably died from the vehicle accident
even this is the thing we don't really
have proper data even
right we don't have prop we have no we
literally have no idea how many people
have had coronavirus
have you have you been tested i have not
have you
no no yeah we could have had i don't
know yep
i i could have passed through me all
right i don't know you don't know
most people have not been tested and
certainly haven't had the antibody test
so
we literally don't know right half of
new york could have had it
right five i don't know four or five six
million people
could have already had it we don't know
you know it could be uh we
we literally do not know so even when
you're talking about
you're trying to do these calculations
and you know even if you're talking
about like death rates or hospitals
they're basically made up numbers
because it's all based on the more
people you test
the more the cases there are right so
so if you test if you tested all 330
million americans
then the number of cases inverted commas
would probably spike like
20x because you've actually tested
people you want to hear an even crazier
one so uh my brother recently
um started writing a bunch about uh the
business and money behind sports
right so he creates this thing and when
he first started i was like you know
what's he going to write about he's
going to write about the contracts of
somebody or whatever
but earlier this week he put together a
piece on covent testing of professional
athletes in the state of florida
and what ends up happening is these
professional sports are all restarting
their leagues
in that specific state and they're doing
things like 10
000 tests a week for the players the
trainers the coaches the support staff
all this stuff and they're trying to
make sure inside of these like bubble
like areas
well the professional athletes get the
results back in 12 to 24 hours
but the general public is supposed to
get it back in five to seven days and
could take up to ten days
and so he basically was like look you
can't you know make a direct comparison
but there's definitely this like
oh one group gets to get the results
faster
and has better access to testing versus
another group
and so when you start to test the public
in that scenario
all that number that gets reported is
here's how many people tested positive
yeah but it could be that the percent of
people being tested is going down
but again it's just this aggregate
number and it's on cnn and all these
places and it's like hey here's how many
people got tested
or in the mba's case they say nobody has
tested positive in the last two days
yeah okay that's great but there's like
300 people right right you could have
tested two people yeah
like it it's just it to your point i
think we don't know what the data is
and uh it requires people to just say
that like that's not a bad thing to
say is we don't know um and actually
that's probably the more intellectually
honest
thing yeah but that the incentives are
messed up
this is the problem i think everything
we're saying it comes back to incentives
whether you're talking at an individual
level society level
uh sort of science level
politician level it all just comes down
to incentives and the incentives are not
people are not incentivized to be honest
and tell the truth people are absolutely
not incentivized to admit making
mistakes
um people aren't even incentivized to do
the best thing for the
citizenry in some situations because you
know and it's um
it's a shame and i don't know the i
don't know the solutions to
all these things but um i think that
being
trying to be rational and clear thinking
and to at least be willing to discuss
them
without trying to demonize people is
normally a good start to fixing anything
you're making too much sense there my
friend to finish up what uh
what's next for you this year you got
kind of half a year left in
2020 what what are you working on yeah
man well doing more of everything i'm
already doing so
got more episodes of my real talk with
zubi podcast coming
um i had some appearances on some some
fairly big shows which were coming out
um i
am going to start writing my next album
i do want to release a new album in 2021
so i want to get back in my
music zone and just spend a few weeks
you know maybe a month i might just get
an airbnb in some random city and
just vibe out and make a bunch of new
music
um so new music is coming it so my plans
have been stifled like i said i
ins until the travel situation goes back
to normal i was hoping to spend a lot of
time out in the states this year but
that won't can't happen until the travel
ban is uh
is lifted so just kind of doing more of
what i'm already doing and continuing to
develop and grow and do it better
i already do all the things that i want
to do i'm just trying to do them more
and do them better and reach more people
with them so
um yeah can expect more of everything
you love about zooby
i'm a fan anyone who uh who has not
listened to the music or read the book
you're an idiot go do it where can we
send people
twitter and where else you want to send
them yeah sure um i'm at
zoobeemusiczubymusic on all social media
platforms
and if you go to if you want to check
out the book or music or anything you
can go to teamzubi.com
and all of my uh all my stuff is
available there
so for those that are uh only listening
to this he's got a bitcoin shirt on
and uh this might be one of the first
times i've seen zoobee not wear a team
zooby hat or shirt or anything
so go uh oh he's got hats in the
background okay all right fair
go go uh go go pick one up because uh
he's not lying when he says that there's
uh there's a lot of people
uh walking around in the united states
and elsewhere that are that are rocking
the gear so it's nice all right listen
thanks for doing this we'll do it again
soon
no doubt bro have a good one